[Music]
what
and who is on screen is important
we're all coming to appreciate that more
and more especially given everything
we've witnessed in the past couple of
years
but what's just as crucial may be more
crucial in the long run
is who's behind the camera and even more
crucial than that
who has the money and that's where
charles d
king comes in this good business that
we're building
is absolutely going to make the world
better the stories are being told
about a community that are actually from
a community instead of a lens of being
told from
from someone else though king isn't
exactly a household name
few people in the entertainment industry
have more influence on what gets made
watched and talked about black and other
minority artists have claimed a growing
share of mainstream power and
recognition over the past couple of
decades
king has often been there behind the
scenes making the right deals
empowering fresh talent and ultimately
starting his own company centered on
creators of color
charles is always like a a voice
that reminds me to look at things like
from a 10 000 foot view you know where
you where do you want to be in five
years 10 years
and he automatically has our ear and our
trust he's been
very very instrumental in my life i
visited charles at his home in beverly
hills
i wanted to find out how he made his way
from sorting mail at a talent agency
to reshaping the landscape of
entertainment
[Music]
so let's let's start at the beginning if
we can
georgia the childhood like we're going
all the way back
look i was born in harlem yeah and then
my family moved south uh
when i was four but then we landed in
atlanta in the suburbs in decatur
it was a nice middle-class neighborhood
and it was great i mean i
grew up playing soccer and tennis and my
father's a pediatrician
and i saw him build this thriving
practice and have his own business
during that time
king went to college at vanderbilt
university in nashville lured by a
generous scholarship
the tennessee capitol is of course a
city of entertainers
the young king was drawn to the business
side of the industry
but he was also inspired by a television
show whose casting foreshadowed his
own work changing who was on the screen
this show that i used to watch with my
mother back in high school called
l.a law this light bulb went off in my
head this character played by blair
underwood this charismatic intelligent
african-american man and i i was like oh
like that blair underwood character that
could be really cool when i go to law
school
my life experiences growing up as a
young black man
in our country seeing some challenges
and issues that we're dealing with there
were some experiences i had during that
time that
also had an interest for me in civil
rights
and so i thought let me go to howard law
and and yet
you probably could have like you could
have been blair underwood or the blair
underwood character in many ways and
like gone to work for a big law firm
and you know sort of taken that path it
was clear for me too
that that wasn't the path for me the
summer after my second year i got a
clerkship
at mtv and one of the lawyers that i
worked with there said hey charles
i think you would make a really good
lawyer but you'd make a great agent
okay and i had no idea about the agency
world and i learned about all these
moguls in the industry
david geffen and barry diller mike ovitz
had just come out of caa and was
had this incredible gig at disney that
didn't work and
one his one year payoff was 95 million
so i was like wait a minute this
agency world and i thought that actually
could be a good fit for me
so king headed west as so many have in
search of a future in hollywood
with his then girlfriend and now wife
stacy
and also like many before and after him
fame and fortune
were not immediately forthcoming so this
is
like this is where it started this is
where i started when i came to la
i said let me start at the oldest
entertainment business in the industry
and at the time it's the william morris
agency
and that legendary agent training
program and they were located right here
in this building
i mean you are at at that point like
incredibly well
credentialed academically and the way
that the world worked
and probably still works to some extent
is you got to go work in the mail room
yes i mean what does that feel like at
that moment
it was it was tough it was very
challenging financially
you know 90 hours a week for very little
pay
at 100 000 in student loans i had to
defer them
there's a a big reason why they're
particularly at that time there are not
many people from diverse backgrounds
in there one it's hard to get in but two
financially it's
challenging to afford it there were no
african-american trainees when i started
there were a few assistants throughout
the building let's say if there were
two or three hundred assistants maybe
there were two wow
and but it was no different in any of
the other ways
that was just what the shape of the town
was the analogy i used to use of
what it was like coming up through the
ranks it's like working on the floor
of the stock exchange you know ticker
tape and people yelling and screaming
rolling phone calls you got four or five
lines going working with
and representing at times i mean up to
maybe like 100 artists so frankly
you know the the threshold of pain of
literally
constantly putting out fires and solving
a problem and i i can't think of a
better training ground
for what i'm doing now king didn't stay
in the mail room for long
quickly working his way up to assistant
then junior agent
just as many had before where he went
off script as it were
was with his client list whether it was
packaging the hit movie barbershop
or repping andre 3000 and dmx king was
becoming a king maker for black culture
i would share all of the statistics and
articles about the shifting demographics
and where we're going
and that you know hip-hop culture is
is youth culture and youth culture is
pop culture and everything is going in
that direction and these are the
demographics that are growing
and that the same thing is going to
happen in film and television that point
of view started to look pretty prescient
in 2005 when a couple of charles's film
clients
hit the big time after you know talking
about tyler perry for years in meetings
inviting people out to see his plays
we'd package his first movie dive with
mad black woman and
you know set up this unprecedented deal
for him at lionsgate to
co-finance and own the movie and that
small
film was you know a massive hit it made
like 50 million the box office and it
sold i don't know a ridiculous amount of
dvds
and it became the cornerstone foundation
of you know this incredible business
that tyler has built and so that
happened in 2005.
craig brewer was a young filmmaker that
i started representing about a month
before sundance that year he had this
movie called hustle and flow
feel that you know it's hard out here
for
up here hustle and flow went to sundance
and
that film made for three and a half
million became the biggest sale at
sundance that year
and then a few months after that we
started representing terrence howard who
got nominated for academy award that
later on that year
and uh yes i went from regular agent
2000 to
a senior vice president by 2008 who was
running our big motion picture meetings
as you as you kind of like this is a
good business it is absolutely and
you're representing some of the biggest
names in the world
and yet you say yeah but i want to do
this other thing
when i went into the mail room it was
with a vision of a 10-year plan to one
day be at the helm
of my own diversified entertainment and
media company i definitely knew
okay this vision that i have this is now
the time for me to begin to put the
put the pieces in place king left his
job to start macro in 2015
he was determined not only to create a
flourishing entertainment business
but to fulfill a social mission as well
centered around a radically and
historically underserved community of
creators and audiences
over time we created this thing called
the macro rubric and there's six key
points that we look for
at the center of every one of the
projects people of color must be at the
center of it either the lead
co-lead the driving through line and you
know people of color on the broad center
african-american latinx asian the wide
different demographic that i call of
the new majority and and so we
choose project one they have people of
color at the center of them projects
that have
a level of excellence and storytelling
and the other thing we of course look
for
in all of the years of experience is
we're looking at what is the business
opportunity for them we're going to take
some calculated risk
but here's where the upside opportunity
is for it
his stature within entertainment the
client list alone
would seem to make starting macro a
fairly low risk proposition
it wasn't he and his wife stacy
self-funded for six months while
investor after investor
passed it's not a slam dunk when you go
out to
to pitch it to people not at all were
you surprised it was
it was harrowing when i made the leap i
knew that there were going to be some
roadblocks and that there might be some
challenges
but that if anyone had the credentials
in the background to do it
that i stood about as strong a shot as
anyone
ever would up to that point how come you
ain't never liked me
like you who the hell said i got to like
you
macro's momentum really picked up when
they co-financed the movie fences in
2016.
starring denzel washington and viola
davis the adaptation of the august
wilson play helped define what macro
would be at its core
combining star power artistic
seriousness and commercial potential
and the oscar goes to viola davis
[Applause]
[Music]
but macros projects with their largely
black-centric stories and creators
would continue to run into challenges in
the marketplace
one striking example would be their
highly acclaimed gothic southern drama
mudbound in 2017.
if we could look at the uh laptop um i
want you to watch what uh
one of your one of your pals said about
a very specific movie
let's check it out the pal in question
ted sarandos the ceo of netflix nice
friend to have
our first deal really we did together um
was
uh mudbound i was in park city the last
couple of days of sundance
mudbound had not sold yet um my team had
i think had taken a pass on it early and
charles called me up and said ted i know
um i know that you would get it would
you
please do me a favor and see the movie
and i i said look there's not even a
screening charles i can't even screen it
anymore he goes no i'll get it to you
and brought over the screener for
mudbound i was able to watch it
and the next morning i was at the
breakfast table with dee reese making
the deal for mudbound
and did very well for us we're very very
proud of that work
and you think about that that little act
of charles knowing to call me
and him being right about it which he
always is um and mudbound became our the
first netflix original movie to be
nominated for an academy award
so that's a pretty good endorsement tell
me that story from your perspective
it's a very very real story we knew we
had a great film
and where we were with the offers from
the other
distributors was crickets things
weren't looking good and ted i just
called him up and said hey ted look you
know i don't reach out to you on a lot
of things but
i think this is one that will resonate
with you and then the rest was history
but the other thing that that movie show
when they did share the data with us
that movie was seen all around the world
at one point i know it was the
25 million hours of the film were viewed
on their platform and they
showed us like a quick map of it it was
global
that notion that certain content does
not travel
this is a story about a friendship
between a young african-american
and a young white guy shared
connectivity to veterans coming back
from war two families black and white
just trying to like live their lives
right just basic universal themes and
wanting better for their families
and this notion that these stories can't
travel it was shown
on that platform and that global
platform it's just not
true
macro stayed true to the principle of
having people of color at the center of
the creative process
and the work varies widely in subject
and tone
soon after mudbound came sorry to bother
you a darkly comedic at times
fantastical movie
set in an alternative present-day
oakland
king was also setting in motion series
like hentafi
that's about a trio of latinx cousins
who saved their grandfather's taco shop
and it's currently in its second season
on netflix
all of that success set up what would
become macro's defining project today
judas and the black messiah black
panther director ryan coogler identified
judas as the project he wanted to
produce
after that blockbuster and teamed up
with director shaka king to tell the
true story of a radical leader
who was brought down by the fbi without
even thinking about it was one of the
easiest decisions that
i had ever made it was like we got to
take this to charles you know it's got
to be a macro project
so that you know we can we can walk into
studios once we have a solid script we
can walk in the studios with half the
funding
you know what i'm saying and just and
just you know take some of the pressure
off
because we know that the pressure is
going to be there and we say look we're
making a period film about you know the
illinois chapter of the black planet
party it's gonna be a predominantly
black cast you know and you wanted to
come in with
you know in a position of power you know
what i mean and
that that charles was the only person we
could go to for that
this is history that people need to know
yeah and the only way that we can really
heal as a country
is by recognizing past issues and things
that have happened
and it was something that we felt like
compelled to get behind and yes there
was a level of
of risk to it but then we also saw the
upside opportunity
and the oscar goes to daniel kaluya
[Music]
i'd like to thank my team um incredible
support
charles king man everyone at macro
and how much does the oscar nominations
and all of that
sort of award buzz do for not just the
film but candidly for for the company i
mean
this feels like an inflection yes sort
of catalytic moment for macro yes
business-wise it's absolutely con
clearly
is opening up more doors we were already
you know doing well i mean we've had 15
academy award nominations for movies
we've either financed or produced
but i'd say now it's really going to be
about continuing that work but also
we're going to expand
we're building a company that i believe
within five to seven years from now will
be a billion plus
diversified entertainment and media
company
it's safe to say something is changing
in hollywood
from a more diverse slate of oscar
nominees to nbc ditching the golden
globes
to the commercial and critical success
of movies like judas and one night in
miami
not to mention the fierce anticipation
for black panther
sequel wakanda forever people of color
finally seem to be getting a seat at the
table in show business
not just creatively but on the business
side as well
i'd say we're getting to a place where
we're within the system
i still don't look at myself like uh
we're you know
one of the establishments or anything
like that but i do think that by our
success
it absolutely inspired and pushed others
who have now taken the entrepreneurial
path
and the thing about it is it's clear
that the
the content this in this space is
resonating commercially so many
successes that we could point to over
the course of the last few years from
hidden figures black panther crazy rich
asians you know
everything rocks in because the rock is
a brother he's a he's black and simone
period right
right so we know the value of our
culture right
and now we just need to be a part of
that value chain of ownership
right we're coming to the table to be
partners as opposed to
saying please can you make this movie
there's a difference in that
and then that absolutely creates more
opportunity for those coming after us
and in my opinion creates more
opportunity for everyone
you